So I have been talking about compile time errors as the big thing that static
typing gives you. Let me explain what that means. So when we run a Python
program, well we write the program we feed it as imput into the Python
interpreter and the Python interpreter runs the program, jumps around our code
and if at some point we get a type error the program will crash. With a staticly
type language like Java, things are quite different. You write a Java program
instead of running that right away, you feed that into what's called a Compiler.
This is the program that takes the Java program, produces a Compiled program. In
the case of Java that's called Java by codes. It's called different things for
different language. But the other thing the Compiler does, is it looks at the
entire program. So it's reading an entire program in. If there's anywhere in the
code for that program, there's a type error, it's going to give a compile time
type error. That means it'll stop, it'll warn the programmer something's wrong
with their program, go fix it. You can't even run the program even if maybe that
type error is somewhere in the code on all the executions you actually do. You
would never actually encounter, if there aren't any type errors if the programs
okay the compiler outputs a compiled program which then is input into the java
interpreter and that's what runs the code. At the point where the codes running
we know that there aren't any type errors in it because the compiler would have
caught them and stopped the program from even producing a compiled program and
even being able to run in the first place. So that means with a statically typed
language like Java, we're getting them before we even run the program. With a
dynamically typed language like Python, we're getting our errors later. We're
not getting them until we encounter that part of the program in an execution.